بالعوده للمظاهره في العاصمه العراقيه
بغداد دعما لصمود قطاع غزه وتنديدا
بالمجازر المرتكبه في القطاع معنا من هناك
مراسل الجزيره عامر لافي
عامر نعم عبد القادر بالفعل انا في احدى
المظاهرات الاسبوعيه التي تخرج في كل
اسبوع بعد صلاه الجمعه في بغداد في مختلف
مساجد بغداد بعد صلاه الجمعه وبالتالي
اليوم في حي اليرموك في وسط الع الصمه
العراقيه بغداد خرجت هذه المظاهره ثم
تحولت الى مسيره واريد ان ابدا قبل الحديث
عن المظاهره عن هذه القائمه التي اعدها
المتظاهرون لاسماء شهداء غزه الذين سقطوا
منذ السابع من اكتوبر الماضي قائمه طويله
الاف الشهداء سقطوا في هذه الحرب التي
بداتها اسرائيل على قطاع غزه وبالتالي
المتظاهرين اعدوا هذه القائمه الطويله جدا
من اسماء الشهداء الذين سقطوا وفي غزه
طبعا
اي العديد من المتظاهرين مئات يشاركون في
هذه المظاهره التي تحركت كما ذكرنا بعد
المسجد بعد صلاه الجمعه وتجوب شوارع منطقه
اليرموك في وسط العاصمه بغداد الجميع طبعا
يندد بما يصفونه بالمجازر التي ترتكب في
غزه على مراه ومسمع من العالم دون ان يحرك
ساكنا الجميع يطالب بدعم غزه يطالبون ايضا
بالعراق لان يقف مع جنوب افريقيا في
الدعوه التي رفعتها امام محكمه العدل
الدوليه يطالبون ايضا الحكومه العراقيه
بسحب قوات التحالف من العراق بعد المشاركه
كما يقولون الفاعله بل لا والتي تقود هذه
الحرب يقولون ان الولايات المتحده هي التي
تقود الحرب وليس اسرائيل وبالتالي هم
يطالبون ايضا باخراج القوات الدوليه كما
تشاهدون ربما هذه احدى المطالب من
المتظاهرين بان تقف العراق وتنضم الى جنوب
افريقيا كطرف ضد اسرائيل في دعوه الاباده
الجماعيه كما يقولون في محكمه العدل
الدوليه كما تشاهدون ايضا ترفع العديد من
اللوحات والصور التي تصف نتنياهو بانه
مجرم بان اسرائيل تقوم بارتكاب مجازر
ويطالب العالم بوقف هذه الحرب ال الهمجيه
كما يصفونها على قطاع غزه طبعا المظاهرات
هي نوع من فقط من نوع واحد مما يقوم به
العراقيون دعما لغزه نعلم ويعلم الجميع
بان المقاومه العراقيه ايضا تقوم بقصف
القواعد الامريكيه سواء في العراق او في
سوريا بشكل شبه يومي عبد القادر كما تعلم
وبالتالي وفقا للامريكان انفسهم اكثر من
130 عمليه استهداف للقواعد الامريكيه سواء
في العراق او في سوريا منذ السابع من
اكتوبر وما زالت مستمره وكما ذكرنا يوميا
ربما تصلنا البيانات التي تتحدث عن
الاستهداف بالمسيرات والصواريخ لهذه
القواعد والمطالبات كما ذكرنا المستمره
لاخراج هذه القوات القوات الامريكيه من
بغداد ومن العراق بشكل عام هنا نعود الى
المظاهره الكثير من المتظاهرين والكلمات
التي تلقى للمطالبه بدعم صمود الشعب
الفلسطيني ووقف ووقوف العراق بكل ما يمكنه
سوا دعما معنويا وماديا وبكل الوسائل مع
غزه لايقاف هذه الحرب وايقاف سيل الدم كما
يقولون المستمر منذ السابع من اكتوبر على
غزه وفي الضفه ايضا عامر لافي من بغداد
شكرا جزيلا لك